as gold wire isn't it okay so it's what
we probably see it so gold is an element
one of the few elements that I think
everybody is very familiar with women
and many men wear it as a wedding ring I
don't wear a wedding ring because as a
chemist I'm frightened that it will
react with mercury and gold silver and
color and will therefore no longer look
nice so here we have a very very fine
sample of grade one research quality
gold so everybody knows that gold we
used to make mimic rings and lots of
jewelry and we do that because it's
inert it doesn't react with anything at
all gold used to be recently to be used
quite a lot for filling of people's
teeth because all false teeth because it
is chemically very unreactive and gold
like silver is an element that is found
naturally in the in rocks and stone
actually as metallic gold in fact I like
most of the other elements it is largely
found as metallic gold this is why
people pan for gold and so on because
they fall of the heavy pieces fall to
the ground so we can happily wear it for
many many hundreds of years and it will
not oxidize or tarnish Gold is very
dense so if this was made out of gold I
just couldn't lift it up because it
would be just too heavy and the mines
that make platinum and get platinum and
the other noble metals also get quite a
large amount of gold at the same time
because gold occurs naturally with a
greater abundance than these other
metals gold obvious is also a storage of
wealth because of the fact that it's so
inert in terms of value
I think this gold is probably maybe
about 10 pence that's it it's probably
more expensive than that actually it is
grade one recently chemists have
realized that gold although it's
chemically rather and react
if can form very good catalysts and so
that there is a lot of research going on
at the moment to try and see what gold
can and cannot do
because as it is much more abundant than
other heavy metals there's quite enough
gold to make all the catalysts we could
possibly want
at one point 1 7 grams will is fall I
think this probably about 50 milligrams
again I spot that mech in the alchemists
idea of making gold from Layton's own is
completely mad it's not physically
possible however in modern times when
people made got nuclear reactors and
even more when they got so-called
accelerators where they can use electric
fields to make the nucleus of atoms
travel at a normal speed then they can
actually make two atoms bang together
and turn into another one but this is on
a very small scale atom by atom and it
is not a way that you could in dance
truly manufacture if you want to become
rich they're better ways than trying to
make gold